بعد ما ظلت ساحه الحرب بالمسرحا نقل
الكثير من الخطط العسكريه رجعت في الايام
الاخيره حديث عن خطط سلام لانهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا لكن هذه التلميحات تجد الابواب
من صدى امامها في ظل تشبط كل طرف بشروط
غير قابله للتفاوض اوكرانيا التي تستعد
لعقد قمه السلام في الذكرى الاولى للعمليه
العسكريه الروسيه قدمت خطه استعراضتها او
استعرضت فيها شروطها لتحقيق السلام التي
لم تاتي باي جديد بخصوص نقاط النزاع مع
موسكو فما كان للاخيره الا ان ابدت رفضا
كليا لهذه الخلطه
الله كريم لنا اوضح ايضا اسباب رفضه لهذه
لهذا المقترح حيله شدد على ان اي مقترحات
اللي انهاء الصراع في اوكرانيا يجب ان
تاخذ في عين الاعتبار حقائق اليوم في ما
يتعلق بالمناطق الاوكرانيه الاربعه التي
اعلنت روسيا ضمها اليها مؤخرا وهذه هي
عقده الحل طبعا ذلك يتعارض معه كليا مع
شروط كيف التي تؤكد على ضروره استعاده
وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه كما كان عليه
الحال قبل العمليه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
خلال الحرب في اوكرانيا فان سباق التسلح
بلغ اشده بين الجانبين الذين
اتهامات بهذا الخصوص الموضوع لا يستثنيه
نوع من الاسلحه حتى الرقميه منها
النائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
بتزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه الرقميه بشكل لا
يمكن السيطره عليه وهو امر محفوف المخاطره
على العالم باسره على حد قوله اضاف
المسؤول الروسي ان عدد الهجمات
الالكترونيه على روسيا في عام 2022 ارتفع
بنسبه 80% وتحديدا منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه على اوكرانيا
الاسلحه الرقميه هي عباره عن برامج
الكترونيه متطوره تسمح بتعطيل او اختراق
بيانات مؤسسات حكوميه او غيرها بالاستعانه
بقراصنه الكترونيين اه بشكل عام فان الهدف
الرئيسي للهجمات الالكترونيه الاوكرانيه
كان المؤسسات الماليه فضلا عن مرافق
البنيه التحتيه للمعلومات الحيويه
والمؤسسات ذات الاهميه الاجتماعيه